I never thought that I would be giving
my TED talk somewhere like this but like
half of humanity I have spent the last
four weeks under lockdown due to the
global pandemic created by Kovac 19
I am extremely fortunate that during
this time I've been able to come here to
these woods near my home in southern
England these woods have always inspired
me and as humanity now tries to think
about how we can find the inspiration to
retake control of our actions so that
terrible things don't come down the road
without us taking action to avert them I
thought this is a good place for us to
talk and I'd like to begin that story
six years ago when I had first joined
the United Nations now I firmly believe
that the UN is of unparalleled
importance in the world right now to
promote collaboration and cooperation
but what they don't tell you when you
join is that this essential work is
delivered mainly in the form of
extremely boring meetings extremely long
boring meetings now you may feel that
you have attended some long boring
meetings in your life and I'm sure you
have but these UN meetings are next
level and everyone who works there
approaches them with a level of calm
normally only achieved by Zen masters
but myself I wasn't ready for that
I joined expecting drama and tension and
breakthrough what I wasn't ready for was
a process that seemed to move at the
speed of a glass ear at the speed that a
Gracia used to move that now in the
middle of one of these long meetings I
was handed a note and it was handed to
me by my friend and colleague and
co-author Christiana Figueres Christiana
was the executive secretary of the UN
Framework Convention on Climate Change
and as such had overall responsibility
for the UN reaching what would become
the Paris agreement
I was running political strategy for her
so when she handed me this note I
assumed that it would contain detailed
political instructions about how we were
going to get out of this nightmare
quagmire that we seem to be trapped in I
took the note and looked at it it said
painful but let's approach with love now
I love this note for lots of reasons I
love the way the little tendrils are
coming out from the word painful it was
a really good visual depiction of how I
felt at that moment but I particularly
loved it because as I looked at it I
realized that it was a political
instruction and that if we were going to
be successful this was how we were going
to do it so let me explain that what
I've been feeling in those meetings was
actually about control I had moved my
life from Brooklyn in New York to Bonn
in Germany with the extremely reluctant
support of my wife my children were now
in a school where they couldn't speak
the language and I thought the deal for
all this disruption to my world was that
I would have some degree of control over
what was going to happen I felt for
years that the climate crisis is the
defining challenge of our generation and
here I was ready to play my part and do
something for Humanity but I put my
hands on the levers of control that I've
been given and pulled them and nothing
happened I realized the things I could
control were menial day-to-day things do
I ride my bike to work and where do I
have lunch whereas the things that were
going to determine whether we were going
to be successful we're issues like will
Russia wreck the negotiations will China
take responsibility for their emissions
will the US help poorer countries deal
with their burden of climate change the
differential felt so huge I could see no
way I could bridge the - it felt futile
I began to feel that I've made a mistake
began to get depressed but even in that
moment I realized that what I was
feeling had a lot of similarities to
what I'd felt when I first found out
about the climate crisis years before
I'd spent many of my most formative
years as a Buddhist monk in my early 20s
but I left the monastic life because
even then 20 years ago I felt that the
climate crisis was already a quickly
unfolding emergency and I wanted to do
my part
but one side left and I rejoin the world
I looked at what I could control it was
the few tons of my own emissions and
that of my immediate family which
political party I voted for every few
years whether I went on a March or two
and then I looked at the issues that
would determine the outcome and they
were big geopolitical negotiations
massive infrastructure spending plans
what everybody else did the differential
again felt so huge that I couldn't see
any way that I could bridge it I kept
trying to take action but it didn't
really stick it felt futile now we know
that this can be a common experience for
many people and maybe you have had this
experience when faced with an enormous
challenge that we don't feel we have any
agency or control over our mind can do a
little trick to protect us we don't like
to feel like we're out of control facing
big forces so our mind will tell us
maybe it's not that important maybe it's
not happening in the way that people say
anyway
or it plays down our own role there's
nothing that you individually can do so
why try but there's something odd going
on here is it really true that humans
will only take sustained and dedicated
action on an issue of paramount
importance when they feel they have a
high degree of control look at these
pictures these people are caregivers and
nurses who have been helping humanity
face the coronavirus Cove at 19 as it
has swept around the world as a pandemic
in the last few months are these people
able to prevent the spread of the
disease No
are they able to prevent their patients
from dying some they will have been able
to prevent but others it will have been
beyond their control
does that make their contribution futile
and meaningless actually it's offensive
even to suggest that what they are doing
is caring for their fellow human beings
at their moments of greatest
vulnerability and that work has huge
meaning to the point where I only have
to show you those pictures for it to
become evident that the courage and
humanity that those people are
demonstrating makes their work
some of the most meaningful things that
can be done as human beings even though
they can't control the outcome now
that's interesting because it shows us
that humans are capable of taking
dedicated and sustained action even when
they can't control the outcome but it
leaves us with another challenge with
the climate crisis the action that we
take is separated from the impact of it
whereas what is happening with these
images is these nurses are being
sustained not by the lofty goal of
changing the world but by the day-to-day
satisfaction of caring for another human
being through their moments of weakness
with the climate crisis we have this
huge separation it used to be that we
were separated by time the impacts of
the climate crisis were supposed to be
way off in the future but right now the
futures come to meet us
continents are on fire cities are going
underwater countries are going
underwater hundreds of thousands of
people are on the move as a result of
climate change
but even if those impacts are no longer
separated from us by time they're still
separated from us in a way that makes it
difficult to feel that direct connection
they happen somewhere else to somebody
else or to us in a different way than
we're used to experiencing it so even
though that story of the nurse
demonstrates something to us about human
nature we're gonna have to find a
different way of dealing with the
climate crisis in a sustained manner
there is a way that we can do this
a powerful combination of a deep and
supporting attitude that when combined
with consistent action can enable whole
societies to take dedicated action in a
sustained way towards a shared goal it's
been used to great effect throughout
history so let me give you a historical
story to explain it right now I'm
standing in the woods near my home in
southern England and these particular
woods are not far from London and 80
years ago that city was under attack in
the late 1930s the people of Britain
would do anything to avoid facing the
reality that Hitler would stop at
nothing to conquer Europe fresh with
memories from the first world war they
were terrified of Nazi aggression and
would do anything to avoid
facing that reality in the end the
reality broke through Churchill is
remembered for many things and not all
of them positive but what he did in
those early days of the war was he
changed the story the people of Britain
told themselves about what they were
doing and what was to come where
previously there had been trepidation
and nervousness and fear there came a
calm resolve an island alone a greatest
hour a greatest generation a country
that would fight them on the beaches and
in the hills and in the streets a
country that would never surrender that
change from fear and trepidation to
facing the reality whatever it was and
however dark it was had nothing to do
with the likelihood of winning the war
there was no news from the front that
battles were going better or even at
that point that a powerful new ally had
joined the fight and changed the odds in
their favor
it was simply a choice a deep determined
stubborn form of optimism emerged not
avoiding or denying the darkness that
was pressing in but refusing to be cowed
by it
that stubborn optimism is powerful it is
not dependent on assuming that the
outcome is going to be good or having a
form of wishful thinking about the
future however what it does is it
animates action and infuses it with
meaning we know that from that time
despite the risk and despite the
challenge it was a meaningful time full
of purpose and multiple accounts have
confirmed that actions that range from
pilots in the Battle of Britain to the
simple act of pulling potatoes from the
soil became infused with meaning they
were animated towards a shared purpose
and a shared outcome we have seen that
throughout history this coupling of a
deep and determined stubborn optimism
with action when the optimism leads to a
determined action then they can become
self sustaining without the stubborn
optimism the action doesn't sustain
itself without the action the stubborn
optimism is just an attitude the two
together can transform an entire issue
and change the world we saw this at
multiple other times we saw it when Rosa
Parks refused to get up from the bus we
saw it in Gandhi's long salt marches to
the beach we saw it when the
suffragettes said that
calls to courage everywhere and we saw
it when Kennedy said that within ten
years he would put a man on the moon
that electrified a generation and focus
them on a shared goal against a dark and
frightening adversary even though they
didn't know how they would achieve it in
each of these cases a realistic and
gritty but determined stubborn optimism
was not the result of success it was the
cause of it that is also how the
transformation happened on the road to
the Paris agreement those challenging
difficult pessimistic meetings
transformed as more and more people
decided that this was our moment to dig
in and determine that we would not drop
the ball on our watch and we would
deliver the outcome that we knew was
possible more and more people transform
themselves to that perspective and began
to work and in the end that worked its
way up into a wave of momentum that
crashed over us and delivered many of
those challenging issues with a better
outcome than we could possibly have
imagined and even now years later and
with a climate denier in the White House
much that was put in motion in those
days is still unfolding and we have
everything to play for in the coming
months and years
on dealing with the climate crisis so
right now we are coming through one of
the most challenging periods in the
lives of most of us the global pandemic
has been frightening where the personal
tragedy has been involved or not but it
has also shaken our belief that we are
powerless in the face of great change in
the space of a few weeks we mobilize to
the point where half of humanity took
drastic action to protect the most
vulnerable if we're capable of that
maybe we have not yet tested the limits
of what humanity can do when it rises to
meet a shared challenge we now need to
move beyond this narrative of
powerlessness because make no mistake
the climate crisis will be orders of
magnitude worse than the pandemic if we
do not take the action that we can still
take to avert the tragedy that we see
coming towards us we can no longer
afford the luxury of feeling powerless
the truth is that future generations
will look back at the
precise moment with all as we stand at
the crossroads between a regenerative
future and one where we have thrown it
all away and the truth is that a lot is
going pretty well for us in this
transition cost for clean energy are
coming down cities are transforming land
is being regenerated people on the
streets calling for change with a verb
and tenacity we have not seen for a
generation genuine success is possible
in this transition and genuine failure
is possible too which makes this the
most exciting time to be alive we can
take a decision right now that we will
approach this challenge with a stubborn
form of gritty realistic and determined
optimism and do everything within our
power to ensure that we shape the path
as we come out of this pandemic towards
a regenerative future we can all decide
that we will be hopeful beacons for
Humanity even if there is our dark days
ahead and we can decide that we will be
responsible we will reduce our own
emissions by at least 50% in the next 10
years and we will take action to engage
with governments and corporations to
ensure they do what is necessary coming
out of the pandemic to rebuild the world
that we want them to right now all of
these things are possible so let's go
back to that boring meeting room where
I'm looking at that note from Christiana
and looking at it took me back to some
of the most transformative experiences
of my life one of the many things I
learned as a monk is that a bright mind
and a joyful heart is both the path and
the goal in life this stubborn optimism
is a form of applied love it is both the
world we want to create and the way in
which we can create that world and it is
a choice for all of us choosing to face
this moment with stubborn optimism can
fill our lives with meaning and purpose
and in doing so we can put a hand on the
arc of history and bend it towards the
future that we choose yes
living now feels out of control it feels
frightening and scary and new but let's
not falter at this most
crucial of transitions that is coming at
us right now
let's face it with stubborn and
determined optimism yes
seeing the changes in the world right
now can be painful but let's approach it
with love thank you
[Music]